we have a great guest on this joining us
now is larry kudlow former director of
the national economic council who's
making his fox news debut today larry
it's great to have you here thank you so
much for joining us
this morning um i wanted to start off
with a question about what's it like
on the other side of your time of the
white house i know it takes a long time
believe me i remember
to sort of rest and recover and feel
restored and ready to go
how are you doing
well i feel restored and ready to go
how's that um
thank you for having me on the show and
uh thank you for having me in the fox
family it's a wonderful opportunity
i look forward to it i'm very energized
i can't wait to go i couldn't think of a
better pair
to begin uh than bill hammer and dana
perino two old friends of mine
you're coming and i hope we get to
talking to this this uh
two trillion dollar package which
doesn't make much sense to me
but anyway i feel i feel great i played
indoor tennis yesterday
um we've taken some time off judy and i
we're all right
larry welcome and we're going to have
many times to talk in the future two
bits of sound from sunday
first year at bernstein with chris
wallace and fox news sunday
watch look the american people
really couldn't care less about budget
process whether it's
regular order bipartisan ship
whether it's filibuster whether it's
reconciliation
they need relief and they need it now so
the urgency here
is the cost of inaction and the plan
is scaled to finally meet the challenge
okay so
there is the message on fox here larry
is the message on cbs this is cedric
richmond
a white house advisor watch
if you think of all the frontline
workers that are out there risking their
lives
every day they shouldn't have to work
two jobs just to
make a living wage and you can make that
a separate poverty line
look the other people want to argue
process
we want to argue purpose in moving this
country forward so they were arguing the
same thing american people care
about progress and not the process how's
that process gonna go do you think
well i think you know my friend jared
bernstein good man
we disagree on some things but he's a
friend i i think he's right i don't
think the issue here is about
process or reconciliation uh
which needs only 51 votes republicans
have used that tool
in the past i think it's about policy
however i mean look
let's take one thing that has nothing to
do with anything is as far as covet is
concerned
and that's raising the national minimum
wage you know who that's going to hurt
the most
that's going to hurt african-americans
hispanics other minority groups it's
going to hurt the poorest part of the
workforce
because once you get outside of let's
say new york and california
maybe illinois the cost of living is
much
lower in all these states and these
small businesses that are desperately
trying to reopen
they can't afford it and therefore
they're going to lay off workers
i mean i love a maximum wage i think you
ought to grow the economy
with low taxes and regulations and so
forth and that'll get
everybody a job and that'll get them up
to maximum minimum wage
but federal legislation never works it
costs jobs it damages those who need
them the most
and it's a terrible idea you want to do
it at the state level
let the states parcel through that i
probably might not like it
but nonetheless it should at least be a
state level regionally
you can't do it by nationwide uh dictat
the other point i want to make is
i think one of you made it we don't even
know
how much money has been spent or not
spent
from the prior packages that's the odd
thing about this there is no accounting
i've seen no
numbers i've been checking around with
all my contacts
from the march cares bill that was
repurposed
in december we don't know how much has
gone to the ppp
small business initiative we don't know
how much is out the door
on the unemployment assistance we don't
know how much has gone through the
states and localities
we should be assessing the economy
before we dive into another 2 trillion
package
which i must say is something of a
democratic wish list so
those are some of the biggest problems i
want to talk about the economy by the
way because
we are still in a v-shaped recovery the
economy is very strong i read about this
economic crisis
i don't believe it and i can prove to
you that it's not there
but it is acute for some people and
that's one of the
problems that the republicans seem to
have with the administration's approach
which is
at the huge trillion the multiple
trillions of dollars that they want to
spend it's very broad brush
and instead of being very targeted to
individuals that actually need it people
who've lost their businesses restaurant
owners
things like that and the other point i
wanted to ask you about is that chuck
schumer
the democratic majority leader in the
senate he said the republicans proposal
is a no go for him because there's no
state and local money
in it that was a big sore point i know
earlier on
last year tell me about those two issues
well look at as far as i can tell
the white house package or the schumer
pelosi package has about 365
billion dollars for states and
localities you know
they have already received hundreds of
billions
of dollars and you really have to ask
yourself
do they need that kind of money and how
is the accounting for the prior
assistance been made again
what is spent and unspent i don't think
that number is nearly enough by the way
state revenues across the country
including places like new york and
california
are actually rising not falling because
the economy is much stronger
than people are suggesting so i i think
that's a very key point look i'm okay
i'm okay with strictly targeted funding
particularly for health vaccination and
school
openings okay i'm okay with that i'm not
okay with spending stimulus checks
sending out and spending stimulus checks
on one penny or two penny stocks which
is what's been happening
with this incredible story of uh
gamestop and
other some of these uh penny stocks
that's so silly
any money given out should be strictly
targeted to the lowest
end and i'd like to see what the prior
legislation accomplishes
let's have an accounting let's know i
think senator portman said there's
one last point go ahead
i'm sorry to interrupt i understand uh
i heard a story i think it's true and
you could check me out on this
teachers in northern virginia
received the vaccinations and they still
because of the teachers union refuse to
reopen the schools and go back to school
now that is nutty and what i'm saying is
a lot of this spending money is going to
democratic interest groups
it is not going to the general health
and welfare of the country it is not
going towards covet
vaccination money fine legitimate school
opening money fine
giving out stimulus checks so people can
buy penny stocks
not fine not good i think rob portman
set up a 900 billion hasn't been spent
yeah so
that's the number that's been out there
fair point we really don't know what it
is
uh keystone decision i know you don't
like it i wonder what the practical
effect of that is
over the next four years or four years
plus china engagement you had a strategy
what's theirs well look at
on the keystone and no drilling uh
no fracking on federal lands no leasing
and drilling and so forth and the paris
climate agreement what you're getting is
the first policies of the new
administration
which will come down very heavily on
energy we are
energy independent thanks to president
trump's actions
uh pipelines infrastructure
drilling fracking uh we've stopped
importing foreign oil
we are stronger at home and abroad
because of it
the buy administration looks in the
early going
to want to roll that back and we'll have
decimating
uh terrible impacts on the economy
keystone itself
has been variously estimated at 10 or 12
000 jobs lost
but it's just going to build from there
i do not think we are in
any kind of environmental or global
warming crisis we could talk about that
some other time
the data do not show that this has just
become kind of a
a religion or a left-wing mantra it's
not there
on china policy uh bill i
i see ambiguity here okay i see
ambiguity
uh first of all some of the people
speaking out on china have said
that we will continue to be tough on
china that president trump's policies
former president trump's policies will
not
be repealed regarding so-called tough on
china
the phase one trade deal is moving ahead
uh we left tariffs on to police that
deal
i don't know how that's going to be
disposed uh some of the cabinet
appointees
have been less than clear about keeping
huawei out of the united states the
telephone company
which we have banned it's on the
so-called
uh export ban list or the uh blacklist
that's important to keep so i i've heard
some good things about china policy
and i've heard some ambiguous things we
don't exactly know yet we must stand
tall
with china they are they are a
competitor but i think
increasingly they are an enemy of the
united states particularly regarding
national security
and we must protect the crown jewels of
technology
that was the thrust of president trump's
china policy
that's what lighthizer and i and
minutian worked on
the crown and wilbur ross the crown
jewels
of our policy must protect new
technological advances
which is the heart of the uh creative
destruction economy it is the heart of
making america the fastest growing
can i ask you one last question here
obviously you loved your time
at the white house you love your life
you're a you love it i want to know what
you have for breakfast in the morning
because i want to try to replicate it
but i also asked this is there something
that was left
undone something that you didn't have a
chance to finish
during the trump administration that you
wish you would have had a chance to do
well look yes of course on policies and
by the way i think
while i may disagree with president
trump's you know behavior in the last
couple of months
i think in policy terms he was a
brilliant consequential president
we could have gone further dana on
tax reduction and reform pro-growth tax
reduction reform
because our tax cuts helped those who
needed it the most it was the middle and
lower end we
could have gone further on deregulation
in my judgment
uh we went across the board but i still
think there was unfinished work to do
we made great progress on 5g all the
telephone connections
ultra fast telephone connections uh
which we spearheaded at nec
but we could have gone further we made
great progress there i would have liked
to have had
uh more opportunities uh there are a
number of areas
frankly unfinished you mentioned the
last couple of months when was the last
time you talked to president trump
i spoke to him on the thursday before
the inauguration
um we had a lovely i don't know
20-minute chat
he was very gracious he was very kind he
was very complimentary
uh we talked mostly about our
achievements as an administration in the
policy areas that i mentioned and and
then some
uh he was much calmer at that point did
you talk about that's
great about the events of january 6th
larry
no we we did not we did not um
i think the president knew my view uh he
put out some very good videos
abhorring violence towards the very end
i wish
he had done that two months earlier and
stayed with that i've always felt
bill i've always felt that when the
electoral college voted
mr biden as president-elect
president trump would have been better
advised to
talk about his great policy achievements
in foreign policy the middle east for
example china
and an economic policy uh we were having
a gangbuster
uh recovery even now we are in a
v-shaped recovery
while this pandemic continues to play
out i would have preferred that
and um you know i think at some point
the republican party
uh needs to think about really saying
from these crazy far-right groups just
as these crazy
far left groups both parties ought to
just say we we don't want your type
we do not i remember my dear great
friend
and mentor the late william f buckley he
threw out the john birch society
in the 1950s he just threw him out
through his magazine national review
and the republican party followed suit
because
they were extreme crazed anti-semitic
and so forth there was no room in the
gop
i would like to see uh president trump
and other spokespeople throw out some of
these crazy groups
and i think democrats should throw them
out on the left wing as well
but president trump phenomenal policy
achievements he will go down in history
for that
and um my guess is we have not heard the
last from him on a number of things
larry we we have a lot to talk about
thank you for the time today but
we're out of time to be continued look
out for perino she's a tough one okay
welcome to the fox family welcome larry
thanks for being here
thank you i appreciate it very much
great to be here appreciate it